do you have a favorite Bond song
yeah I guess well it's hard to beat Live
and Let Die but I think Skyfall is
really creeping up there but the
instrumental for Honor Majesty's Secret
Service is amazing because that's the
only one without lyrics it's just John
Berry right yeah wow do you watch a Bond
film every day yeah I wake up to it
so it's not even it's not it's not a
sound that you wake up to you wake up
because a projector turns on yeah and
you watch a full uh 85 minutes sometimes
I hire live actors to do a stage show
that's nice and then you get a little
massage afterwards hello why do you get
a massage
from Timothy Dalton I have oh my God
incredible he gets right in he gets
right in there right where the shoulder
blade in between the roller blades so
it's a matter of fact he's amazing
obviously people do a show he has really
strong hands but he's also knows where
to apply the pressure yeah God bless you
too God bless you sometimes he'll rub
like your
scapula with that little cleft in his
chin and yeah
[Laughter]
you know why have you stopped looking at
me no but so many times he's so good at
getting the cleft right in because the
little you know sometimes yeah the
little knot that you have yeah he gets
that cleft right over it it's like
running a credit card it is it's like
running a credit card and I think about
that all the time when I look at Timothy
Dalton's chin when it's rubbing up
against my back oh I just looked we lost
our last listener yeah wait they're
coming back nope they turned around and
walked away is he still
only two bonds are dead Roger Moore died
on my birthday
I can't think of anything worse well
that and you know why
and you know what happens
it's because you went to visit him
he's such a bond fanatic he went to
visit Roger Moore he went to visit Roger
Moore on his birthday rang the bell more
who was just recovering from his seventh
heart attack opened the door and he went
surprise it's my birthday James Bond
Roger Moore fell dead you killed it he
killed James Bond accidentally oh man
yeah he also surprised man Sean Connery
died on your birthday because he was
surprised at the door by someone in a
loincloth and said I love you 007 the
point is the remaining before look out
don't answer the door on gorly's
birthday
to to the following memo is for for all
the surviving James Bonds do not answer
your door on Matt gurley's birthday and
if you do make sure that you have CPR
equipment with you
defibrillators
[Music]
and a surgeon
I love maybe my favorite Bond too what I
know
so much
too like
Percy at the end he's he's like guys
in the last one oh man I think he's like
72 57. I'm sorry he's 72 during the last
year that he plays James bonder maybe 82
I'm not sure but they literally show him
it's the one that has the um uh there's
a acrobat kill yeah if you do a kill and
there's an acrobat in it uh you know
woman no there's a woman who's a gymnast
remember that
well there's Grace Jones who's does like
martial arts no I thought there was a
woman are you thinking of octopussy no I
never think of octopussy I do
um I do
I'm thinking of it right now
I'm so sorry I'm laughing so hard that's
okay just look I understand what I'm
saying now what I'm saying is he I think
in his last James Bond he actually like
drapes a coat over a sleeping woman's
shoulder you know while she's passed out
because he's become completely asexual
towards the end bake a quiche in this
movie
what in beautiful kill yeah also it's
got the worst
use they they felt like they needed to
say A View to a Kill in the movie which
you don't no you don't have to say A
View to a Kill but they they're in a
Zeppelin and they're riding towards
their target and someone says wow quite
a view yeah Grace Jones yeah Grace Jones
has quite a few and then um Christopher
Walken says yeah A View to a Kill he
like looks into the lens when he says it
but I remember anyone saying it sure is
Thunderball in Thunderball so what the
[ __ ] I don't understand why did they
feel the need to do that
I I don't know it's a good question
we've got to get this title in yeah does
anyone ever say Quantum of Solace and
Quantum no they never do no because you
can't because it doesn't mean anything
bad like the the new Specter is called
Quantum I know but yeah
anyway look for that moment I'm not
interested in James Bond so let's wrap
this up I'm sick of this you hate it